hey what's up my name's samuel leaves
this is a video for the complete and
utter
idiots that comment on my youtube
channel
so if you are not an absolute [ __ ] if
you're a sensible person
then you don't have to watch this video
because i've been having
absolutely loads of people over the last
few days talking about the rent control
petition
that i started a few days ago and the
stuff that they're saying
is outrageously incorrect and wrong
but also very very dangerous and could
potentially if
people actually believe what's being
said and literally i'm not just talking
about internet trolls or i'm talking
about people
publishing this on websites it is nuts
so let me explain what's happening right
now
um okay so number one
sadiq khan was re-elected
as mayor of london recently okay
number two sadiq khan said
that if he is re-elected he is going to
fight for the power to introduce
rent control to london
number three rent control means that the
rent
in an area can be capped so the
government
control what the rent is this used to be
the case in the uk
many years ago and it absolutely ruined
the housing market it's happened in
other countries
like in berlin and it's ruining berlin
they are short on 50 of their housing
stock in berlin right now
they tried it in new york and it ruined
the housing market in new york
the left and the right economists agree
that rent control is an absolutely
devastating thing
for the market it hurts the people it is
trying to help
those are the three points there's no
confusion at all now what people are
saying
is they're saying that the petition that
we have started
that by the way has already had 2 000
signatures when it gets to 10 000
signatures
that the government are going to have to
respond i want them to respond
and hopefully when they respond they
will respond by saying
thank you we've heard your voice we've
looked into it and you are correct
rent control does not work and we can
confirm that we will not be introducing
rent control
to this country because if it happens in
london
it will set a precedent this has already
been talked about
it's going to set a precedent and it
could then very easily be
duplicated in manchester in leeds in
birmingham
across yorkshire the north south east
west
so we cannot have rent control coming
into london
now this is what the crazy more moronic
people are saying they're saying
oh the petition don't bother signing the
petition folks
it's void because sadiq khan hasn't got
that kind of power anyway
city can't bring rent control it doesn't
have the power so don't sign the
petition
what the whole point of the petition
is to tell the government not to allow
siddique
to have the power which he is fighting
for we know that he doesn't have the
power
to bring in rent control as it stands
otherwise we would have
rent control what we are saying in the
petition
is we are pleading with the uk
government to not
give siddique the power that he is
fighting for
very very simple so i'm shocked
at the ignorance of some of these
writers
it is crucial that we stand together
as landlords investors entrepreneurs and
tenants
and employees and working class and
middle class
it's it's it's absolutely imperative
that we stop rent control happening we
cannot have the government dictating
what we can and cannot charge for rent
we need a free market a free market
we cannot strip the rights away from the
tenants and from the landlords because
what will happen
is it will lead to empty properties it
will lead to
tenants being in properties that
landlords are resentful and they refuse
to do prop work on the property
it will lead to developers not buying
and building
homes where we have a massive shortage
of homes that's why
rents are really high in london anyway
rents are already down in london by 14
percent
from siddiq's last run as mayor
so rents are dropping in london if we
bring in rent control it will distort
and ruin the market
for tenants and landlords alike so
please
please if you're watching this and you
would believe in all of the clap
trap that's being spouted by the media
by online forums by internet trolls the
absolute
nonsense i would love to debate some of
these people
some of these people that talk with such
confidence online when they are so
moronic i'd love to debate them
i opened up a debate about rent control
before had a wonderful guy called hakeem
who was an elected official for the
labour party
he came in and we had a very
sophisticated debate about
rent control which actually confirmed my
position in my mind and in my followers
mind
in my opinion even more but if you're
watching this video
and if you haven't signed the petition
take my word for it okay
do some research and get the petition
signed we cannot have this happening in
this
beautiful country the land of
opportunity we cannot have this
happening
so sign the petition i'll leave it in
the link below we need to get it to ten
thousand followers
another thing i want you to do send a
petition
to all the property influencers you know
send it to the property influencers
the people with voices the youtubers the
instagramers the property trainers
the letting agents send it to them and
ask them to share it
far and wide get your family signing it
get your friends signing it this is not
a samuel leeds petition
it's not about me this is about this
country
so get it shared far and wide we need
to get to 10 000 signatures right now
we're on 2000
help me get it to ten thousand
if we don't do it soon they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna close it and
scrap this in total and then
rent control could be introduced and it
could ripple across the country and it
could mean that
suddenly property investment becomes a
very ugly
thing in this country and i don't want
to see that happen
sure there'll be opportunities there'll
be ways you can step around it and of
course
but they cannot take away the free
market in this industry this is
serious so share it far and wide
share the petition fair and wide get it
signed
do it today pass it around
let's get to 10 000 signatures and let's
demand a response
from the government about this serious
serious issue